what's the penalty for losing?
Football to the head?
I Suppose so, yeah.
You got it.
No!
Here we go again then.
Great.
Six years later.
Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
A while ago Dan, I threw
a ball in your head.
Apparently I've seen the video
but I don't remember it at all.
Did knock the memory
clean out of your head.
I'm pretty sure my IQ point
just went on the floor.
That was filmed 1000
frames a second but today,
we have a camera that will
do 28,000 frames a second.
Let's do it again.
Maybe you will knock the memory back
into me with this one.
Maybe as this hits your head,
you'll go back in time six years.
Yeah, I'll just forget everything
since it happened then.
We didn't really show
this in the first video
but it's not easy to get
water into a football.
Well it takes time because imagine
you're pumping and pump and air comes out.
You sort of get
because obviously water is thick and
What's worse it's going
through a needle nose,
takes a lot of time.
I shove that back in there.
So you just have to let the air out
and then shut one of these
needles in fill it with water.
You can hear it.
It's nearly full.
You have to let it sit in the water.
Oh, that's hefty.
You think that'll rattle your brain?
Yeah.
Oh God, that hurt already.
I don't wanna do this.
Rattle my brain.
Hurts enough with a football full of air.
Playing football, I don't head the ball.
'Cause it hurts?
Yeah, I'm like, "Why would I do that."
Well you lose brain cells.
Exactly, I'm not doing that.
I don't like the amount
of time I get like,
"Get a head on it."
I'm like, off.
Alright last time you went
for a sort of toothy grin.
Yeah.
This time I reckon a flabby
face sort of gormless look.
Okay, we'll see what we can do.
And if you can keep your
eyes open, that's a bonus.
Alright.
Critical focus.
Ready?
Yeah.
Ugh, Got it, yeah.
I just relaxed, just relaxed.
That's gotta be it.
Alright do it again.
Do it again.
Wait until my eyes have been
open for a few tries, okay?
For a few tries?
Well, that's gonna psych you up.
Nah, I found my zone, I found my zone.
I found it.
I just imagine that you're
shaking like maracas next to me.
And I'm not gonna get hit.
Sweaty hair.
Is a bit hot out.
Ugh, that's it.
That was it.
I think so.
Yeah, look at that.
Oh, it's a clean hit at
the side of the face.
Oh, the shock waves at-
Oh, your nose bone moved under your nose!
Ooh!
My eyes' like, "What's happened here."
Oh, now the shock hit your
face like hung behind.
Oh, no.
I don't think I could-
You look like someone else.
Who's that?
It's so stupid.
I look like I'm asleep there,
I'm like really peaceful.
Oh, it's class.
The first part of it stayed there
but the rest of it moved.
Crazy.
That was class.
I like it a lot better slower.
It's like bloody 30 degrees
out here, 35 degrees.
I actually need to take
that thing off, hang on.
Feel good?
Yeah.
It's like we've got our own pool.
Oh, no.
I mean, people spend a
lot of money on pools
but you really just don't need one.
You could just get a dustbin
and fill it full of dirty water.
Get a gammy old bin and fill it
with hose water and it's the same.
Yeah, and a pump.
And a bike pump.
Whoa!
Yeah I lost another two IQ points there.
What are you down to now, 67?
73. Give me some slack.
73, all right.
Geez!
It was fascinating slower.
Yeah.
Like I never thought
I'd see the nose bone,
move under the nose.
Like I saw exactly where your nose ended
and where this the gristle and cartilage.
It was just perfect.
Yeah, imagine what mine
would have been like.
Yeah, it would still be there.
The end of it would've flown off!
Your face would be off the frame.
What's interesting is that
usually when we do a slow mo,
it's like, "Alright,
here's comes the ball,
here comes the ball."
Now you're getting hit.
Now you're bouncing away.
With this camera, it's like,
"Alright, here's the ball.
Now you're getting hit,
you're still getting hit,
you're literally still
getting hit by a ball."
And it goes on forever!
True.
It's amazing.
I look fluffy in slow motion for ages.
For ages.
So that was 28 times slower
than the first time we did it,
and hopefully in six or so years,
we'll be doing it even slower than that.
I will give you enough
time to rebuild the IQ.
I'll be like 50 or, goodness sake.
Do you think each time you
get hit more IQ falls out?
Yeah, definitely, yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed that revisit.
Feel free to follow us on Twitter,
give the old one a watch,
it was pretty funny.
We got behind the scenes channel
and we've got much.
So whatever you want to do at this point,
and we will hope to see
you in the next video.
See you in seven years
when I get hit again.